schauen sie mal was hang zu einer sagen
was sie das hängen sie sehen einen
glücklichen mann der den youtube trader
erwartet er praktisch gewonnen was das
ist ja wurscht ich haben jedenfalls und
zwar kennt man den für
100.000 da stets 100.000
subskription enten praktisch das macht
mir wirklich machte wahnsinnig stolz und
ich weiß gar nicht wohin der wahn wieder
solle jetzt überlegen vielleicht im
westflügel genüber oder oder in
ostfildern ist mir eingefallen ich habe
gar kein ostflügel westflügel lernen
dann doch ins wohnzimmer gar zur disco
großes wohnzimmer ist mehr so wohnküche
ist eigentlich geht und
da hängen hilfe nur platzes an der wand
weil hauptfenster dann wirst du dich
schon mitbringen